[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen zur zehn
minuten nachrichten und die sportlichen
siege niederlagen die hat norbert
lehmann für sie ein stück von unsere
großen themen heute
jetzt das eingeständnis russland gibt zu
den ukrainischen hafen odessa gestern
doch beschossen zu haben
zankapfel panzer ringtausch weil er
nicht funktioniert wollen die grünen
direkte lieferungen von kampfpanzern in
die ukraine prüfen
und überraschender platz auf dem
treppchen bei der leichtathletik-wm in
den usa freut sich die deutsche frauen
sprintstaffel über bronze in
der ukrainischen häfen laufen die
vorbereitungen für die ausfuhr von
millionen tonnen getreide aber nach dem
raketenangriff auf wo das in russland
jetzt eingeräumt hat ist in der ukraine
die sorge groß dass sich russland nicht
an das getreide abkommen halten könnte
und sich dadurch der export verzögert
über die lage nach genau fünf monaten
krieg berichtet thomas kunz
usa ein sommertag im krieg baden
schwimmen im meer alles lebensgefährlich
warnung vor seeminen hinzu kommt die
bedrohung aus der luft gestern der
beschuss des hafens mindestens ein
schiff brannte aus ein angriff auf dem
getreide transport sagt die ukraine
russland hatte gestern noch die attacke
bestritten heute gibt moskau sie zu
getroffen habe man aber waffen nicht
weizen wir haben eine ukrainische
kriegsschiff zerstört und mit präzisen
raketen vom schwarzen meer aus ein lager
für hapoel raketen zum beschuss von
schiffen geliefert aus den usa der
wichtige hafen angegriffen am tag nach
der export einigung mit russland dennoch
bereitet die ukraine transporte vor und
russlands außenminister zu besuch bei
der arabischen liga in ägypten
versichert dass für die welternährung so
wesentliche abkommen stehe dazu gehöre
russland die türkei und ein weiteres
land begleiten die konvois zu den
meerengen zur kontrolle der ukrainische
präsident traut solchen worten nicht
bereits vergangene nacht sagt er
wenn irgendjemand auf der welt noch sagt
ein dialog mit russland seien nötig
sieht man jetzt russische raketen
zerstören vereinbarungen zugleich zeigt
sich salewski zuversichtlich
siegesgewiss genau fünf monate nach
kriegsbeginn zwar gab es für pro
russische einheiten im ostukrainischen
dombach geländegewinne seit zwei monaten
nach und nach doch im süden nahe der
stadt kasan sein ukrainische truppen
dabei gebiete zurückzuerobern
odessa ein sommertag ein kriegstag der
151 seit dem russischen einmarsch
gerade kam diese nachricht noch rein la
france hat sich noch geäußert und gesagt
das ziel der russischen militär
operation wie star genannt wird der
spezialoperation also des russischen
krieges sei ein regime wechsel in katar
und der ukrainische präsident fordert
erneut mehrere schwerere waffen aus dem
ausland in deutschland mehren sich nun
die stimmen die für eine direkte
lieferung auch von panzern in die
ukraine sind also ohne den umweg über
den ringtausch mit östlichen nato
partnern denn der stockt und der ukraine
läuft die zeit davon ein bericht von
simon pfanzelt
andauernd wird die panzer reparatur
einheit der ukrainischen armee gerufen
immer ist irgendwo etwas kaputt eine
raupen kette gerissen eine batterie leer
die armee ist am anschlag die grünen
fordern jetzt mehr direkte
waffenlieferungen aus deutschland
das muss alles auf den tisch was geht
dass die ukraine ausgestattet wird mit
dem was sie braucht unser versprechen
hieß ja wir wollen der ukraine helfen so
lange wie möglich und mit allem was wir
können es müsse ein umdenken geben weil
der von der bundesregierung versprochene
ringtausch bislang nicht funktioniere
geplant war das östliche nato partner
wie etwa polen und tschechien ältere
panzer sowjetischer bauart in die
ukraine liefern das ist auch passiert
im gegenzug sollte deutschland diese
länder mit modernen waffen ausstatten
doch dazu ist es bislang nicht gekommen
den polen soll deutschland zuletzt 20
leopard-2-panzer angeboten haben ab
april 2023 zunächst nur einen pro monat
die reaktion und diplomatisch deutlich
die deutschen versprechen zum panzer
ringtausch haben sich als
täuschungsmanöver erwiesen so der vize
außenminister uns wurde eine symbolische
anzahl panzer angeboten das kann man
schwerlich als ernstzunehmenden
vorschlag werten nachdem wir der ukraine
über 200 panzer in zwei monaten
geliefert haben aus den beständen der
bundeswehr seien die lieferungen nicht
möglich heißt es aus dem
verteidigungsministerium
es liefen gespräche mit der
rüstungsindustrie
die opposition wirft der regierung
wortbruch vor wenn die bundesregierung
diese waffen nicht wie von will dann
soll sie es sagen aber sie darf nicht
öffentlich einerseits so reden und dann
ganz anders handeln streit über
waffenlieferungen in deutschland während
die ukraine auf material wartet
cdu-chef märz hat sich im zdf
sommerinterview von den äußerungen
seines parteikollegen dem sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten kretschmann
distanziert manchmal hatte darauf
gedrungen dass deutschland zwischen
russland und der ukraine vermittelt so
das zitat dieser krieg eingefroren wird
wie sich friedrich merz über den ukraine
krieg und seine folgen im interview
geäußert hat erfahren sie von patrizier
wiedemeier
es ist seine heimat sein wahlkreis
winterberg im sauerland ort des
sommerinterviews mit dem cdu
vorsitzenden friedrich merz es geht
natürlich um die folgen des ukraine
krieges um die künftige
energieversorgung ohne atomkraft werde
ist nicht gehen wenn das russische gas
ausfällt so merz gesagt ihnen auch
voraus wir werden am ende des jahres
sehen was die laufzeit der
kernkraftwerke verlängert wird gab es
vorgeschlagen die bundesregierung lehnt
ab wenn die bundesregierung mit uns
reden will ernst kraft treten was sie
zurzeit nicht tot wir bieten das immer
an aber wir laufen der bundesregierung
nicht hinterher die ampelkoalition sei
jetzt in der verantwortung die probleme
zu lösen aber märz gibt zu dass die cdu
fehler gemacht habe in den letzten 16
jahren ich bekenne mich zu der
verantwortung die die cdu in der zeit
hatte ohne jede frage und wir
diskutieren natürlich darüber wir wissen
dass wir fehler gemacht haben aber wir
waren die alleine von diesen 16 jahren
waren zwölf jahre die sozialdemokraten
dabei es gibt aber auch innerhalb der
union viele strittige themen das
verhältnis zu russland die einführung
einer frauenquote oder eines tempolimits
dieses jedoch lehnt märz ab das
tempolimit ist ein symbolthema damit
würden wir auch wieder ökologisch noch
verkehrstechnisch die probleme lösen
rückblick und ausblick es gibt viel
aufzuarbeiten es gibt große
herausforderungen auch für die union und
in voller länge gibt es das
sommerinterview mit friedrich merz
gleich nach unserer heute -sendung und
natürlich auch in der zdf- heute
miteinander corona sommer welle gibt
streit zwischen dem gesundheitsminister
und dem chef der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung gassen der stellt die
notwendigkeit einer zweiten booster
impfung in frage und kritisiert dass die
regierung für den herbst gleich mehrere
impfstoffe bestellt hat lauterbach
empfiehlt den zweiten booster und sagt
mit blick auf die bestell lage man habe
mehrere impfstoffe gekauft weil man
jetzt noch nicht wissen könne welcher
sich im herbst als der beste erweist
papst franziskus bezeichnet sie auf
twitter als reise der versöhnung das
oberhaupt der katholischen kirche ist zu
einer sechstägigen kanada reise
aufgebrochen wegen schmerzen im knie im
rollstuhl morgen will er sich mit in die
den treffen und um vergebung bitten für
gewalt und für missbrauch in heimen die
von der katholischen kirche geführt
wurden bis in die 90er jahre waren in
kanada etwa
150.000 indigene kinder von ihren
familien getrennt und in heimen
untergebracht worden
in südeuropa lodern die waldbrände
vielerorts weiter zum beispiel in
griechenland auf der insel lesbos
konnten sich die feuer weitgehend
ungehindert ausbreiten weil die böden
extrem trocken sind löschversuche der
feuerwehr blieben oftmals vergebens
strandabschnitte mehrere häuser und
autos wurden durch die flammen zerstört
ortschaften mussten evakuiert werden
und wir kommen zur leichter die wm in
den usa norbert endlich gibt es nicht
eine reihe am vorletzten wettkampftag
wurde ja langsam zeit mussten ganz schön
lange drauf warten immerhin bronze und
immerhin eine echte überraschung denn
die 4 x 100 meter sprintstaffel der
frauen die hatte keiner so richtig auf
den medaillen zettel vier deutsche
sprinterinnen am ziel ihrer träume wm
bronze als lohn für ein fantastisches
staffelrennen stand das glück auf
unserer seite und wir freuen uns
unheimlich es fühlt sich an wie traum
gerade ich hoffe ich mache nicht auf
hinter den großen top-favoriten hinaus
den usa und jamaika erreichen die
deutschen damen ihre bestform tatjana
pinto übergibt den staffelstab an
alexandra burghardt die staffel
großbritanniens fällt mit problemen
zurück gina lückenkemper kämpft und
rebekka haase glänzt im schlusssprint 42
03 sekunden danach fließen tränen der
freude in eugene
deutschlands gegner im fussball em
halbfinale am mittwoch heißt frankreich
fpd schoss in der 102 spielminute den
einzigen und damit entscheidenden
treffer des spiels gestern abend gegen
die titelverteidigerinnen aus den
niederlanden das erste mal übrigens das
label in ein frauen em halbfinale
geschafft haben
zum großen preis von frankreich den hat
formel 1 pilot max verstappen gewonnen
der niederländer im red bull feierte
seinen siebten saisonsieg und hat jetzt
65 punkte vorsprung aus schale claire
der ferrari pilot der von der pole
position gestartet war fiel wegen eines
fahrfehlers aus sebastian vettel dem
aston martin wurde elfter
1 comeback nach 13 jahren die tour de
france der frauen und da ist die
niederländerin lorena wie bis ins gelbe
trikot gesprintet auf der ersten etappe
in paris setzte sich die 23-jährige
gegen ihre landsfrau marianne vos und
die belgierin lotte kopetzki durch beste
deutsche bei der massenankunft ex
weltmeisterin lisa brennauer auf platz
19 ja und in wenigen minuten wird der
däne jonas wigger in paris als
gesamtsieger der tour der männer
gefeiert aber es wird eine große party
dankeschön norbert und so wird das
wetter in deutschland wir von der
nordsee her schauer und teils kräftige
gewitter mit starkregen und sturmböen
sonst freundlich und viel sonne bei 25
bis 36 grad um 21.45 begrüßt sie wohl
schmiese zum heute journal
und hier geht es jetzt direkt weiter mit
dem sommerinterview mit cdu-chef märz
dennoch